We're all ready?
Yep.
Easy.
You guys are all good?
Yep.
Sweet as.
You have more to learn, by the way.
OK, yeah.
So just wondering, what were your first impressions
using the app?
I thought it was really intuitive.
It wasn't hard to find the different screens
that we need to navigate to or do the different ones.
I really like the icons that are at the bottom,
even across the entire page as well,
telling you what each thing does.
So it's pretty like, even if you don't read it, it's fine.
You can still understand what's going on.
OK, sweet.
I think the only really big issue I had with this
was the bottom part, the colors used.
I think that the green at the bottom is a bit too dark,
because it doesn't contrast that well with the black.
So it can be a little hard to read the text,
especially if you didn't have good vision.
I see.
So the bottom part kind of had an issue,
in terms of contrast being a thing.
Yeah.
If there was a bit of a lighter color,
or if it was white on the color instead,
I think it would have worked better.
OK.
Yeah, I guess in that sense, as you mentioned,
now the icons I feel like are fine for me.
It's just like the text at the bottom kind of got blended.
For me, I'm just looking at it right now,
because when I did do the testing,
I didn't even look at the work.
But now I'm looking at it, the text blends in.
So yeah, probably like a lighter bit at the bottom.
OK, a lighter color.
It kind of gives you a good vibe on how to navigate.
Yeah.
That kind of leads quite nicely into our next question,
which is kind of describe your experience kind of navigating
about these tasks.
Like what are kind of some difficulties you had,
all that sort of benefits?
One issue that I heard, I'm actually
trying to remember what the task was.
OK, we had to go to this one, and then help and support.
Oh yeah, the help and support button doesn't work.
Yeah, I heard that issue.
OK, so in the menu, help and support
doesn't direct you to anything?
Yeah.
OK.
But everything else is fine.
I guess for me, since I didn't actually
even click on the help and support,
because I went to contact support immediately.
So it worked fine for me.
But yeah, I guess if we could link back
to this particular page here, it would make more sense
for a user just having more freedom into the app as well.
OK.
Oh, another thing within the app as well,
when it went to dark mode and high contrast,
you can't see the text.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, like Cassie disappears.
So you don't know whether it's been typed out.
Yeah, that's a good bug.
Yeah, so that's one of the minor issues
that can be fixed immediately.
And also, I forgot to mention this within testing,
but it doesn't stay to the thing.
So you don't know whether that's right.
You can kind of, if you read it, you know.
But if you think about it, like, oh, is that what it is?
Sounds good.
What about other kind of tasks?
Did you have any trouble navigating things
besides settings?
Yes.
I know there's a whole button up here to go back.
But I was looking at buttons down.
For me, when I use my apps, I normally
have buttons down here.
I guess it's mainly the user on the other apps as well.
I use TikTok a lot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It has all the, yeah, so I was kind of like, oh, OK.
OK, cool.
And also, it doesn't really have a home button.
It goes to user.
You can go back, but I don't know what happened here.
Yeah, right.
OK, cool.
And no other tasks?
Yeah, what are the things you liked about the navigation
that you would say would be kept?
I think the way that information is laid out
is quite good, especially on the payments.
I like that it's separate to today, past week, et cetera.
So it's not just one big block of text,
because it can be quite overwhelming.
People don't look through all that.
So I think the information is separate as well.
I like how there's also, for that information,
if you press down, it comes up here.
And for a quick, extra information for a user,
it would be like, OK, I paid this person.
Perfect.
And I'll go into another tab.
Yeah, easy.
So yeah.
I also liked how it was similar to past and future
at the top, more than other expenses.
Yeah.
Cool.
I appreciate that.
They're all on Discord.
Yeah, sorry about that.
OK, and a bit of a quicker question.
How do you feel about the color scheme?
No, I wouldn't choose it.
OK.
I think that the shades of green don't match well.
I like the darker greens, but I think
that the lighter green is a different hue,
if that makes sense.
So I think it's too lime.
It doesn't have enough blue in it.
So I would say I like the colors of this.
It's just the top and the bottom half of it,
which kind of doesn't go well with the app.
I would say that's fine.
OK, cool.
So if you were to change that, what would you guys
feel kind of matched?
I would take out the blue.
I would take out the navy blue, and I'd make it white.
I don't think any other color.
Something like white for the border on,
kind of like showing you, hey, you can add more things here.
OK.
Or maybe like having this lighter shades of green
or something similar to that.
Or I would make this white.
The dash would almost take white to contrast it.
Or white.
In fact, swapping the contrast colors, say, with orange,
would you say would be a better option?
Or maybe something more similar.
I would say that you come with the orange,
but I would say it would not go well with this.
I think contrast, well, it just wouldn't look that.
When it comes to color schemes, I
think it's better to be simpler rather than more complex.
So utilizing white and black and contrast
more and using the same two colors
rather than having lots of different shades
of the same color.
I would say having one bright color within the app
for buttons or maybe for something like these
to show, OK, we have color.
But having the two main, maybe black and white or black
and some other color that is focused on the app as well
could represent you as a company and the app as well.
Cool.
Appreciate it.
OK.
And final question.
If it's where we are, would you use it?
Why or why not?
What would be some good things and what
would be some drawbacks using it?
I actually have a really similar app to this
that I use with my flatmates.
And I think that this has more functionality
for doing different things because it tracks your upcoming
payments, which would be useful.
But the app that I use is definitely a lot simpler,
just because it focuses really on those really simple
add an expense and pay it with your flatmates.
So I'd probably stick with that just
because that's all that I need it for.
But if I wanted an app that could
track my expenses and my budget and stuff,
then I think this would be useful.
I would use it.
It kind of reminds me a little bit.
So any significant drawbacks to the experience using the app?
What does it show?
For me, not really.
Nothing in particular.
There were the minor issues that we had.
But other than that, it's pretty good app.
Thank you.
Cool.
Yeah.
I think that's pretty much it.
Rashid, Amish, nothing else?
No.
Cool.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
No worries.
Cool.
So what are all your names?
Rachel.
Arianna.
Karen.
Cool.
Yeah.